this man's football morning in america
column has been uh just as must read as
his uh long time column and his previous
spots he is part of nbc sports for quite
some time and he helps kick off our week
before opening kickoff coverage of the
21
nfl season none other than peter king
how are you peter
hey rich i'm great how about you i'm
trying to make heads or tales of the
charles robinson report and why miami
would do such a thing and what's going
on is there is there any much there
there
um 10 days before
the season begins and 13 days before the
dolphins have to go up into gillette to
start the season that desean watson and
the dolphins are doing a dance with each
other right now i wish i knew rich but i
don't know
um
you know i i wish i was inside this
story
right now but i'm not and give credit to
charles robinson for
uh for
some good information over the weekend
um
it's very very hard for me to believe
that the dolphins would do this or quite
frankly right now that
houston would do this i mean houston
clearly wants to be rid of desean watson
understandably but
how are you going to get your best deal
right now when
deep down inside
you know i don't know how anybody could
know
what the fate of deshawn watson is you
know whether
uh
you know what's going to happen to him
legally i mean is it possible that he
could spend time in prison
i don't i don't think so but is that
possible
uh i mean just what exactly is possible
no one knows and so therefore
i i find it uh i find it
really kind of hard to believe that a
team right now would trade for him not
knowing
what exactly he's going to be able to do
for you this year
and how much this legal situation
is going to chase him
down the road into the future
it just would it it it would shock me to
be honest with you peter and it's
already shocking me that there's uh you
know a possibility of it happening
because charles robinson as you know has
got his
he's he's got t's crossed and eyes
dotted and so
um i just don't understand why like what
would be the point that you might be
able to acquire
desean watson on the cheap at the
expense of
kind of
upsetting the 21 without a car that's
why that's why it's a dumb idea for
houston to do it right now
i mean why would you
why would you make this trade before
i mean you just have to take the crap
that comes with employee employing
desean watson right now if you're the
houston texans
you're not winning anything this year
anyway
uh you basically have the roster of an
expansion team
so
you know if you're not winning anything
this year
then what sense does it make to take a
deal that would be below market i can't
i mean nick casario would you know if he
takes a 50
of of watson's value when watson is is
free and clear of everything he ought to
be fired
i mean you know it does it just doesn't
make any sense to rush into this
you know the texans what the texans
should do
is basically say look we're going to pay
your salary this year just stay away
and we're going to pay your salary stay
away and we're going to trade you next
offseason
and it's incumbent on you to get your uh
to get your legal situation taken care
of so we can trade you next off season
peter king here on the rich eisen show
so you were with baltimore when they
found out
about dobbins is that where you've been
last i wasn't with baltimore no i was
there last week for a day okay
spent time with dobbins i had never met
him before and uh he's really a
delightful guy who was so incredibly uh
excited about um
you know about about playing and about
being
in the nirvana for an nfl running back
which is baltimore
i mean they've averaged uh you know
they've they've run it 56 of the time
over the last two years nobody does that
anymore
and he knew that he was in a solid gold
place
and yet on the ninth play of the game on
saturday night that meant absolutely
nothing his season went down the tubes
so uh
yeah i wrote about that today i just
i really ended up feeling for this guy
so much after uh meeting him and talking
to him and
and and having a big role on a great
team he said for him is
for the same is the same for mo
for most other people as breathing
that's
like all he wants to do in the world so
um i spent yesterday
really kind of bummed out for for jk
dobbins yeah i mean what a horrible
turn of events for him and obviously the
ravens
right on the eve of of the season and
you know uh cam akers didn't get hurt in
a preseason game but that's another
significant young
running back entering year two that
would have been in a perfect position
as well um but what's the general sense
now that this preseason is in the books
that uh the concept of the three games
is there any thought about
um curtailing it off of
some of these injuries that we have seen
i mean it happens all the time if we
kind of forgot he's all the time rich
but i i mean look
you know could there slash should there
be
two preseason games probably every time
i hear a coach say oh we need to
evaluate the players we need the three
games
you don't play half your roster
you know you two games should be plenty
of time to evaluate the 68th guy on your
roster plus you're going to practice
with one or two other teams mo most
teams do that now so
it's it's silly to think that these
games are needed
but the fact is there are going to be
some teams some very very good teams you
know the baltimore ravens the pittsburgh
steelers bill belichick
uh you know in the patriots
they play their guys in the pre-season
and
the
you know i mean
as much as
part of me wants to say man you got to
put these guys in bubble wrap till
opening day
i think i'm not saying there's just as
much danger in that
but
you know in so many cases you know the
new york giants you need to see daniel
jones
try to figure out how he's going to be
able to play with this awful offensive
line you don't want to get into the
first game of the year against von
miller and bradley chubb in the
meadowlands and say oh how are we going
to figure this out now
um and so i again i do think there's
some value especially for up and coming
growing teams to play their guys in
these games peter king here on the rich
eisen show based on who you saw
and what you've seen now that training
camp and preseason is in the books and
now we're just
gonna
go back to our separate 32 corners and
come out and start fighting
um
who which teams were you impressed by
the most seeing
thinking that either they're being slept
on or they're going to be the biggest
problem that we're not talking about
right so i thought 20 teams rich and and
so
you know it's silly like i didn't i
wasn't in cleveland for instance um and
i mean there's
there's a lot of teams i didn't see
they're going to be pretty good i wasn't
in new england
um
but but i'll tell you there's three
teams that
are a little bit different than i
thought they would be like the chargers
in my opinion have a chance to be a very
very dangerous team they're obviously
dangerous offensively
uh and if james and bosa stay healthy
relatively speaking which is a huge if
uh particularly with james based on
recent history
i think that they could end up giving
the chiefs a run for their money
i i mean i know that sounds outrageous
but i really like
uh the chargers
um the steelers were better than i
thought they would be
ben roethlisberger looks like he's lost
i don't know make a guess 15 pounds i
don't know but he looked a little bit
more life and and and light on his feet
um he just looked more athletic to me
when i saw them
and that pat friar moves the the the
tight end
i mean he has got he's got odell hands
he's he really i think might be
a really big good impact player but
obviously so much of that is going to
depend on
whether an all-new offensive line um can
mesh and play well early and the other
team i saw that uh is speaking of
offensive lines you know to think that
the
that that kansas city
is going to play
a guy at left tech who's never played it
in the nfl orlando brown a great left
garden joe tooney and then guys at
center right guard and right tackle who
have never played in an nfl game before
and that's the team you enter the season
with
i mean i i think all is all is great
when you got patrick mahomes as your guy
and those young guys had a really really
good training camp trey smith the right
guard from tennessee
um might have been a first or second
round pick if he didn't have all of the
health problems he had in college but
that those are the three teams that i
was really kind of fascinated by it and
i don't mention tampa because i think
everybody believes tampa
is going to be really really good again
and that um with tom brady being healthy
and knowing everything about the offense
and already having had a great year last
year um
they're going to be pretty good too well
let's get to tampa then um peter king
here on the rich eisen show you've been
there and done that quite a bit in your
career peter you're in the pro football
hall of fame but uh when you sat down
with brady for your previous column i
imagine it's the first time you've ever
sat down with a 44 year old defending
super bowl mvp off of his seventh
championship how did you find brady
when you chatted with him peter effusive
excited
um
you know really really happy content
with his life
happy he did what he did
um it's amazing rich to think that he's
one thousand five hundred and ninety
three days older than any other football
player in the nfl
that's a great number
it's just absurd it's absurd because not
only does he look young he acts young
and the day that i saw him he was
playing mentor slash
teacher to a fourth round smurf
from north texas state a receiver named
jalen darden
um and he's really getting into that
like role
last year was o.j howard
and and and the other guys this year
it's jalen garden he has been really uh
uh sort of
he's really come alive
with a third down back
like he had with james white in new
england
geo bernard this year and i told a buddy
of mine who's a fantasy football player
i said
look i'm not all together familiar
with what really matters in fantasy
football but i do think that this guy
gio bernard is going to score a lot of
touchdowns
and is going to have a chance to be a
really good
red zone player
um and again i don't know what all that
means but he's going to touch it a lot
he's going to be really good
and
you know if anything and you don't know
what's going to happen with injuries but
if anything that offense is better and
you know what rich it was funny an hour
after the super bowl i was talking to
bruce arians you know i was in the same
building as he was but we were talking
on the phone because you couldn't meet
in person then and he said to me you
know he said it sounds crazy but you
know the sad thing is we don't have more
games to play
this is the best we've been all year on
both sides of the ball and it's it's
just a shame the season is ending
and so this was not a team that was
weary at the end of the year this is a
team that was excited at the end of the
year so they've got a lot of different
things going for him this year in tampa
peter king here on the rich eisen show
your best guess on
who the starter is for new england and
san francisco those appear to be the
only outstanding quarterback issues as
we're talking 10 days before the season
peter in both of them well i would be a
little bit more confident in jimmy
garoppolo because
you know all along
um
you know trey lance was going to have to
be
an a quarterback in garoppolo with c
plus through training camp for
for lance to win the job and i do not
think that has been the case
uh in new england
i thought that um i mean i think that
that mac jones is at a better training
camp there's no doubt he's had a better
training camp
but has he knocked the champion out in
the in the eyes of bill belichick not
really
um if i had to guess and that's all it
would be i'd guess that cam newton will
start new england because you know i i
that's it's just again it's so
fascinating to me that the the brady
belichick relationship that lasted 20
years which is something we'll never see
again i mean again i mean reid and
mahomes have to play what 16 more
seasons like mahomes and we're gonna
have to have reed as his coach for 16
more seasons to match it it's insane
it's insane that here we are one year
after the separation brady is the 44
year old defending super bowl champ and
belichick's got a first round
quarterback
competition that's going on in training
camp and with a revamped roster sony
michelle now on the rams the patriots
just fascinate me
right now peter and i i think they have
a chance to be really good this year i'm
wondering what you think i think so too
you know what i noticed i watched their
game last night rich
you know what you notice tonight even
though the giants offensive line stinks
you know what you notice about that
defense in new england they've got a lot
of different weapons
on that front seven that i think are
really going to surprise people you
think of your uh
of your
uh michigan wolverine joshua right who
to me was the most impressive guy
in the game yesterday for for new
england on defense
and
and you know you think about you think
about the different kinds
of pressure that they can get you know
nobody knows who dietrich wise is but
he's he's good joshua is good
uh
kyle van noy
was really good uh when he was in new
england the last time and i still think
he is
i think new england is a really
fascinating team if they get even
efficient play at the quarterback
position last year they got lousy play
at the quarterback position so i mean
rich you and i probably both feel like
it's only a matter of time before before
mack jones plays right
but whatever happens i agree with you i
think they're going to be i think
they're going to be tough all along i
think didn't didn't didn't you go into
the off season thinking well now it's
buffalo miami new england
i i would not put new england behind
miami now i'm not sure i'd put him far
ahead of miami
but i'd probably put
new england just
a nudge uh above miami right now in that
division well i certainly would if miami
goes and acquires a guy it could be put
on the commissioner's exempt list at any
point in time you know that's why i
guess to bring this conversation full
circle it just doesn't really make a lot
of sense until everything
every last chip has fallen where it's
going to rest period before you make a
trade
i can't i mean i can't i just can't see
it now look
it may be it it may be
that
if
the dolphins uh you know it's a very
very progressive organization
and they don't mind taking risks um
if the dolphins feel like absolutely
unequivocally
even if it isn't until opening day 2023
if they know that they want desean
watson to be their guy
and they can get him for a slight
bargain right now and they've got to
dump tua
which i would assume obviously he'd be
involved in any in any trade like that
you know maybe maybe they would do it i
just
i do not see i think it is i'm not going
to call it irresponsible
but i don't think it's smart
to make a trade of that magnitude
without knowing all of the conditions
involved and you can't know the
conditions involved right now peter
thanks for the call i look forward to
chatting you with you so much more
throughout another fascinating nfl
season that we're so fortunate to have a
front row
uh seat on with nbc and peacock and all
that so thanks peter really appreciate
it okay rich have a great week let's
chat soon at peter underscore king right
here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here